Zack Snyder Star Wars not exactly but is
close the intense first teaser for
Netflix's Rebel moon has finally arrived
and it's so packed with detail that
you'll need to light up a laser sword to
slice through it all
Rebel moon is filled with a diverse
array of Talent with stars on display
like Sofia boutella Charlie Hunnam g mon
hansu and even Anthony Hopkins teaser
viewers may not realize that the movie
also happens to be one major Game of
Thrones reunion Rebel Moon happens to
feature both actors who played Dario
Naharis and the iconic HBO series the
role of Naharis was first portrayed by
Ed scrine him audience says may remember
from 2016's Deadpool skrinsteins as
Dario was cut short and the actor was
replaced by Michael Houseman Houseman
continued to play the nefarious
mercenary until season 6 of Game of
Thrones when his love affair with
Daenerys came to an end as fate would
have it both darios were hired for Rebel
Moon by Snyder in the upcoming Netflix
Sci-Fi epic audiences can cease crime
step into the shores of the cruel
Emerald Atticus Noble well details are
slim on the character the first trailer
makes it a point to show that Noble and
his army is nothing to mess with on the
other hand houseman's Gunner is siding
with the good guys joining Korra in the
battle against a devious Imperium
Zack Snyder loves his mythology
[Music]
PC Universe centered around an
interpretation of Superman and heroes
like him as Gods beings of so much power
and responsibility that they transcended
The Human Experience these mythic
storytelling elements are present in
other Schneider films such as Watchmen
Legends of the Guardian the owls of
gahul and of course 300. it should come
as no surprise then that Rebel moon is
full of Hellenistic details and
symbolism there's a distinct aesthetic
that pulls heavily from ancient Greek
myth there are giant stone statues stone
temples and what appears to be a
Coliseum of sorts there's even a
straight up Griffin exchanging the alien
creatures of typical sci-fi for mythical
beasts of antiquity all of these touches
emphasize the strange juxtaposition of
Rebel Moon it sometimes looks like hard
Science Fiction with laser guns hulking
starships and sterile metallic
environments other times it feels more
like high fantasy shirtless Heroes of
long flowing hair fighting to defend
their farming Village it remains to be
seen if Snyder will be able to
synthesize his disparate cameras into a
compelling hole
Jenna Malone and Zack Snyder have a
history together with the actress
appearing in the filmmaker's sucker
punch Batman v Superman and even lending
her voice to an upcoming spin-off of
army of the Dead not that we're
complaining Jenna Malone improves just
about every movie she's ever appeared in
if you're wondering why we're talking
about her you probably didn't spot her
in the trailer yes that's right Malone
is playing the creepy spider Lady In
Rebel Moon she also seems to have a
hostage or victim that she's holding
tightly to her chest when she descends
indicating that she's not exactly
Pleasant to be around she looks like a
force to be reckoned whether she battles
one of the Rebel Moon Warriors there was
definitely not using a lightsaber we'll
get to that later as far as a Spider
Woman is concerned the fact that we've
got monster people in this universe
definitely bodes well for the
inventiveness of Snyder's new playground
and are excited to see what other
strange new creatures might emerge over
the course of the movie's sprawling
story
former king of Asgard and oscar-winning
chianti connoisseur Sir Anthony Hopkins
provides a voiceover in the trailer for
Zack Snyder's upcoming epic and it fits
like a glove the only question is where
is he between the wild looking
Spider-Woman and massive Space Battles
wherever could they fit the icon on the
Silver Screen how about is the voice of
a robot named Jimmy Hopkins is indeed
bringing to life Jimmy the Robot briefly
seen throughout the trailer described as
a robot space Knight Jimmy looks to be
documenting the mammoth events
surrounding Our Heroes and the impacts
they'll have on their world and others I
was given memories of a world I will
never see and love for a child
which I could not save could he find a
second chance in Sofia boutella's quora
flick is a film with a young girl
Shelley had a strong connection with
someone he may have failed to protect
Cora could be the Redemption he needs or
the mission he was always tasked with
achieving what better bodyguard than a
k2so type figure with optional antlers
and who sounds like Hannibal collector
Rebel Moon started as a Star Wars pitch
that's how Zack Snyder originally
conceived the idea and though Disney
decided not to give the director the
Reigns to Star Wars he wound up turning
his story into an original property for
Netflix I'm getting a chance to tell a
story that I've been thinking about for
quite a while even though it hasn't been
a Star Wars movie since the earliest
stages of development there are still
some pretty obvious references in the
rebel Moon trailer the battle against an
evil Galactic Empire was Titanic
battleships and The Smuggler with the
hearts of gold the tropes that Star Wars
didn't create but is certainly
popularized the most obvious bit of
George Lucas's universe and the rebel
Moon trailer though is the two red
lightsabers we ordered by Bay doona's
Nemesis character and the two blue
Sabers that show up in a brief fight
sequence toward the end of the trailer
though we don't know much about Nemesis
the trailer shows that she fights with a
pair of katana as swords both of which
glue bright red like the iconic cyst
lightsabers of Star Wars but are they
actually lightsabers of one closed for
inspection the sword seems to be made of
metal and simply glow red because well
we don't honestly know you this would
distinguish the weapons from lightsabers
but it probably won't stop the
comparisons and the blue swords later on
seem to use the same technology is there
something special about Whitey's weapons
glow do they use material similar to
kyber crystals hopefully we'll learn
more on the run-up to the premiere
there's a whole lot of eye candy to be
found in the trailer for Rebel Moon
that's one of the more mysterious
aspects of it comes down to a literal
eye there's one moment where a group of
people are gathered with bags over their
heads on these bags is a symbol of an
eye with what looks like a teardrop in
the corner later in the trailer there's
a moment where people playing
violin-like instruments where similar
sacks only this time the eye is in Gold
it looks to be in much better shape so
what does this eye mean it's hard to
tell at this point it's an original
symbol for this new franchise but based
on context it likely has something to do
with subjugation or imprisonment the
first group looks like they're about to
meet Grizzly Fates while the violinists
can easily be servants for the ruling
class wearing such head coverings could
be a way for the evil Elites to keep the
underprivileged in check ice symbology
is certainly nothing new in media and
this particular icon even looks similar
to the sheika eye from The Legend of
Zelda series but given the amount of
World building Rebel moon will endowedly
do it's safe to say a thorough
explanation will be present in the
finished product
it's coming for directors to reuse
iconography across their films Zack
Snyder is usually associated with slow
motion and Visually arresting
cinematography but it seems he's also a
fan of characters kicking people in the
chest arguably the most famous scene
from the 300 the movie that puts Snyder
on the map is when King Leonidas kicks a
Persian messenger into a well this is
Sparta
thank you
it was parodied numerous times in a year
since the film came out and for good
reason it's a really cool way of
dispatching an enemy and Snyder's
getting back to his old tracks by
incorporating a similar kick within
Rebel moon at one point in the trailer
General Titus gives a riveting speech
before it cuts to him in combat kicking
an enemy in the chest in a similar
manner to 300.
as the audience says finish watching the
teaser trailer for Rebel Moon you'll
likely be wondering who or what's is the
scar Giver well the first part of Rebel
moon is titled child of fire the second
part is in fact called the scar Giver so
Snyder clearly has big plans for whoever
the scar Giver is and the answer seems
pretty straightforward I found her
seeing his core is a main protagonist in
Rebel Moon it stands to reason that she
is a scar giver and the trailer even
appears to introduce her as such the
real question is if the scar Giver is a
mythological title that exists in the
world of Rebel moon or if the moniker is
simply won that Korra or her enemies
created the trailer kicks off with Jimmy
talking about how the world foretold the
emergence of the Redeemer an individual
who would stop the madness of War seeing
as the world is engulfed in chaos it's
likely that the Redeemer failed in their
mission is it possible that the scar
Giver AKA Cora will be the world's
savior will she evolve from the child of
fire into the scar Giver it seems likely
but who knows what twist Snyder has in
store
[Music]